donald trump les populistes la défiance
des journalistes
de là des citoyens envers les
journalistes beaucoup de thèmes à
aborder dans ce débat ils sont liés vous
allez évidemment le comprendre je
présente mes invités mais ne la mise en
ondes en soi soit grand reporter à l'ops
christophe deloire en soit morale de
reporters sans frontières plaignant du
forum sur l'information et la démocratie
jean bernard schmidt bonsoir journaliste
co fondateur directeur général de sipa
ici et de spicy éduque vous publiez avec
thomas huchon en tiff et nous livre
indispensable pour démêler le vrai du
faux c'est publié aux éditions first
matthieu croissandeau évidemment rester
à mes côtés on démarre avec trump dans
ce débat c'est notre premier chapitre
emmanuelle anizon bon c'est pas une
surprise il l'avait annoncé un de le
voir créer son propre réseau social il
faut se souvenir qu'il a été banni de de
twitter qui était son outil de base
pendant les quatre ans de son mandat oui
effectivement c'est une plateforme qui
est très attendue parce que du côté
français des complotistes français des
antilles vague c'est là j'ai suivi le
convoi
liberté cette semaine c'est quelque
chose dont il parlait beaucoup donc
cette plateforme va s'ajouter à toutes
celles qui le regardent déjà beaucoup en
france et
et ça fait ça fait tout un monde
parallèle qui est quand même beaucoup
d'argent beaucoup de moyens et beaucoup
de puissance qui est quand même assez
assez dingue en fait quand on plonge
dedans on se rend compte que c'est parce
que dans quel état de forme il ya cactus
et avec claude banker il ya odyssée
c'est tout un monde parallèle qui
s'organise et l'éleveur qui sont des
liveurs spécifique aussi et c'est un
monde d'information
qui nous regardent
et m'écoutent plus exactement qui se met
complètement parallèle exactement et ou
qui quand quand il entraîne une brimer
un extrait de journal de la radio leur
loge est par principe est ce que vous
diriez ça avait bien sûr c'est à dire
que ce que ce qui ce qui circule ce sont
des extraits qui sont de fait
décontextualisés et qui servent le
discours pas paranoïaque et enfin aux
complotistes van la parra comme on veut
mais mais il n'y a plus du tout cette
relation direct à l'information dit
meanstream en fait je jean bernard
schmidt se sait au réseau social ce
nouveau média social tous alors si c'est
un bon exercice de prononciation pour
les journalistes francophones ce que ça
fait partie des mots difficiles à
prononcer mais j'y arrive à peu près
qu'est ce qu'on va trouver sur ce sur ce
réseau social est ce que est ce que l'on
sait déjà alors oui on sait on sait
assez parce que très vite il avait
montré ce qu'allait être l'interface de
trousses médias
c'est d'ailleurs aussi à zéro parce
qu'on sentait que le twitter dont il
avait été banni lui manquer parce que ça
ressemble énormément à twitter y avoir
un fil d'infos il des profils avec une
photo etc vous pourrez envoyer des
messages privés le volant c'est un peu
la même chose sauf que là les messages
s'appelle d'égérie tes skis on a dit
assez ironique un le concernant et puis
ce que je trouve assez intéressant c'est
un peu ce que vous disiez c'est que
s'il ya deux choses d'abord tous médias
falls c'est là la première brique de
quelque chose de plus gros seins il a
créé donc le trou strumpf technology et
média group donc ça sera le premier
étage de aussi il veut créer un et flix
son propre netflix ou 10 mai plus et
puis veut créer après sa propre chaîne
d'info en propre cnn donc déjà ça c'est
une première journée la deuxième chose
si on revient à l'essence de ce qu'était
un réseau social pour donald trump on
voit bien et c'est ce que vous disiez
c'est l'idée de réimposer sa propre
narration c'est à dire de se sortir
finalement des contraintes de ce qu'il a
fini par détester ce qu'il détestait ce
qui à ce qu'il le haïssait à la fin
auprès des journalistes c'est à dire
l'obligation d'en passer par un média
mais mieux vaut avoir sa propre capacité
de raconter sa vérité et c'est ce que
trump a fait dès le début de son mandat
on s'en souvient l'apparition d'effets
alternative c'est l'idée que maintenant
il va s'affranchir de tout exactitude
des faits pour raconter sa vérité c'est
ce qui va vouloir faire une vérité
alternative christophe deloire c'est un
mensonge mois sera plus fin il ya un
moment où il faut revenir à
ces que trump est l'un des plus grands
menteurs de l'histoire politique et que
le nombre de ses mensonges étaient
telles que ce qui faisait des
statistiques avait vraiment avec un
travail absolument gagner leur
extraordinaire moi ce qui me stupéfait
là dedans c'est de se dire en fait
derrière un problème il ya toujours un
autre problème et on a eu un problème au
moment des événements du 6 janvier quand
je dis on la démocratie a eu un problème
la taille du capital or le premier
problème c'était la tactique capitole il
ya eu un autre problème c'est qu'à ce
moment là finalement les plates formes
numériques ont pris la décision de
supprimer les comptes de trump dans
l'urgence on pouvait concevoir que
soient légitimes mais néanmoins est
devant quelque chose de vertigineux de
voir ces plateformes numériques avoir un
pouvoir de censure
chacun pouvait en fonction de ses
opinions politiques tous avec l'az était
légitime ou pas et sans contrôle
démocratique
et là on se rend compte et donc avec un
contournement d'une certaine manière de
ce qui avait été installé dans les
démocraties comme appareil pour poser
des garanties avoir des règles discuté
par le parlement
et là on se rend compte que ce
contournement finalement la démocratie
il est lui-même contourner à son tour
puisque donald trump et ses équipes créé
ce réseau social alors qu'ils renvoient
dans le nom renvoie presque à 1984 le
roman de george orwell tellement
effectivement on est dans une forme
d'antinomie avec la vérité et puis je me
souviens bien la vérité c'est en russe
je ne parle pas du tout russe la pravda
oui donc il ya aussi un écho là assez
fort mais donc qu'est ce que les
institutions démocratiques peuvent faire
pour éviter une désintermédiation qui va
toujours plus loin et où effectivement
comme vous le dites chacun et notamment
les plus puissants se comptent plus de
moyens peuvent créer leur narratif sans
la moindre contradiction dans un certain
nombre de busnes on va continuer on va
aussi dans ce débat pas oublier de
se regarder un peu devant la glace parce
que puisque la question c'est la
défiance des citoyens vers les journées
s'il ya forcément une part de
responsabilité des journées si on va pas
la gomme et on va pas échapper dans ce
débat évidemment mais mathieu j'aurais
quand même con qu'on parle du rôle des
politiques et pas seulement des
populistes dans cette déviance en
défiance envers des les jours n'est ce
pas se taper sur les journées c'est
quand même un vieux truc de politique
quand il veut allumer un contre-feu
c'est pas nouveau et c'est pas seulement
donald trump pour les populistes quels
que soient les pays c'est un vieux
réflexe ou la campagne s'avère
généralement bien dans les meetings vous
fait conspuer les journalistes ça
marchait beaucoup à l'extrême droite et
même à droite ça marche aussi maintenant
à l'extrême gauche donc c'est vrai que
c'est un vieux réflexe parce que ça
permet de vous dire il ya quelqu'un qui
filtrent le message que je veux vous
dire il ne vous dis pas le bon message
où il ya quelques chez quelqu'un que
vous raconte des histoires sur moi et
qui ne sont pas les bonnes histoires
classiques dernier en date c'est valérie
pécresse qui traite les observateurs de
bigorneau de bigorneau parce qu'ils
n'ont rien compris ce qu'elle a voulu
dire ami quand même 48 heures nous
expliquer ce qu'elle a voulu dire
peut-être que c'était pas très bien
formulée mais sans avoir sont atteints
bien sûr l'échelle de trump on peut
quand même s'interroger sur cette
volonté aujourd'hui des politiques de
s'adresser directement à leur électorat
via des canaux médiatiques pour tout cas
des canaux numériques dédiés vous prenez
des gens qui sont pas des forcément des
populistes anne hidalgo quand elle fait
sa campagne pour être désigné candidat
du ps s'est fait un facebook live son
journaliste google parle à sa fin de
mi-temps marine le pen fait des facebook
live animée par un fonds au journaliste
ou un ancien collègue c'est un confrère
plus tôt mais qui et qui permet de
raconter absolument ce qu'elle veut avec
des relances et des interruptions des
questions qui n'en sont pas vraiment
jean luc mélenchon a développé et c'est
aussi sa force
non sans partir de son bord d'une télé
jean luc mélenchon il fait des live sur
twitter interrogé par des mélenchonistes
bref on voit bien tout ça fonctionne en
somme dans des clusters idéologique ou
partisans dans lequel il ya plus du tout
où c'est vrai de rôle de filtre ou de
rôle de rôle médiatique pour pouvoir
toucher directement cesser ses militants
et si le les médias en général c'est à
nous les les médias audiovisuels les
médias de la presse écrite les radios ne
s'interroge pas sur la façon dont on
rapporte le message politique la façon
dont on se comporte avec les politiques
je pense qu'on peut aboutir à de vraies
dérives ou où chacun parlera à son camp
les réseaux sociaux les algorithmes
favorise évidemment salle avec la
conversion en effet noté et on sourit on
s'enferme dans un produit devient le
débat public il faut que tout le monde
s'y met nos jours et les politiques bien
sûr mais nous jouerons les soucis sur
comment l'organiser comme on le fait est
là la gouaille la question subsidiaire
est ce que finalement on n'est pas je me
dis même est condamné aux médias
d'opinion finalement dans cette danse
est logique si on continue de dériver
vers cette logique on a tous évidemment
les réalisant pts 2 de ces news et 2 et
voilà de l'évolution j'ai pas voulu dire
dérive de ces news je crois pas qu'on
soit qu'on a misé alors effectivement
les algorithmes nous enfermer en ferme
les gens de plus en plus dans leurs
champs leurs convictions mais je
voudrais revenir cette question de
défiance je pense qu'on a un énorme
travail collectif affaire c'est que si
est cette défiance vis-à-vis de notre
travail c'est que sans doute on n'a pas
non plus bien fait et et moi je vois sur
le terrain puisque je suis quand même
des populations que je suis beaucoup
en fait ce qui ce qui raccroche avec
canton le pouvoir travailler avec eux
c'est prendre du temps c'est pas les
regarder c'est pas regarder les gens de
haut s'est passé des heures passées le
week-end passé des soirées c'est prendre
le temps de comprendre
leur logique non pas de d'y adhérer mais
au moins de pouvoir là
la retranscrit enfin et d'expliquer 2 2
2 pourquoi finalement de c2c de cette
défiance et je crois qu'on a c'est chose
qui manque terriblement aujourd'hui dans
notre métier parce que parce qu'on voit
là on est dans des médias qui vont très
vite parce que les chaînes d'info
continue c'est c'est vrai j'ai vécu
gilet jaune par exemple les tout tout on
se retrouvait tous ce samedi aller là où
il y avait la guerre les gaz à grimaud a
raconté ça à toute vitesse or tout le
mouvement il s'expliquer autrement et
s'expliquer sur les ronds-points le soir
dans les discussions dans les réunions
sur le rique le référendum nice et des
citoyennes par exemple que beaucoup
moins drôle hein c'est sûr à suivre que
les gaz lacrymo ça paraît un peu mon
rallye ça deux balles de dire ça mais
mais je les y croit vraiment
profondément parce que la seule manière
aujourd'hui de de reprendre un peu de
raccrocher un peu de confiance et de
pouvoir discuter de rétablir un lien
c'est vraiment vraiment de prendre le
temps alors je vais m'appuyer sur la
dernière le dernier baromètre de du
quotidien la croix le 35e baromètre des
médias pour évaluer effectivement ce ce
niveau de défiance qui grandit 44 pour
cent des français ont le sentiment que
les médias ne fournissent pas une
information fiable et vérifiées et puis
je disais un peu plus tôt dans
l'émission que je vais redonner ces
chiffres plus aucun média n'obtient une
majorité de confiance auprès des
français à tous les médias sont en
dessous du seuil de 50% c'est la radio
et la presse écrite qui arrive en tête à
49 la télévision 44 internet
24%
c'est un enjeu démocratique majeur quoi
sert que que ce fossé se creuse c'est là
ça on le voit si on l'a vu ça a un
impact sur le fonctionnement des
élections sur l'émergence de certains
candidats sait on est au coeur d'un
enjeu démocratique d' équilibre de votre
démocratie en iran fondamentalement il
l'a toujours été oui quand on a la
liberté et la capacité d'information
c'est un un des piliers fondamentaux de
notre démocratie
et l'a d'ailleurs alors il ya plusieurs
choses je pense que il y a quelque chose
assez profond et vous avez raison
une remise en cause quand même qui doit
apparaître chez nous et je pense
qu'effectivement la rapidité de
l'information la différence entre
fabrication de l'information et
fabrication de l'opinion ce sont deux
choses quand même un peu différente et
notamment la vision alors je veux pas
dire ni caricatural ni tronqué mais on
va dire rapide de certaines actualités
qui sont donnés parce que l'actualité va
vite les chaînes d'info vont vite et
notamment parce qu'elle se discute
autour de plateaux
donne cette idée de plateau avec des
gens qui discutent discuter innues des
éditorialistes dont on a l'impression
qu'ils racontent un peu toujours la même
chose je vous dise à ses larmes là la
perception aussi sur le terrain donne
cette impression que l'actualité se fait
loin elle se fait à paris et elle se
fait dans un studio où on sort pas de
deux justement son confort de studio et
ce qui est vrai c'est que lorsqu'il ya
eu des articles longs des reportages
long qui sont faits sur terre je pense à
la série qui avait fait florence aubenas
justement sur les ronds-points
marmandais cetera ya eu des choses et
des documentaires il ya eu des
reportages long d'envoyé spécial il ya
eu des choses et c'est vrai que dans ce
cas là on sent une perception qui est
différente mais honnêtement ils filent
et qu'est-ce que ça pèse à la fin quand
il ya eu ce rouleau compresseur avec eux
et quand il est l'autre chose l'autre
aux enjeux démocratiques on revient
dessus mais c'est vrai que le la façon
dont les réseaux sociaux
fragmente la société et fragmentent
l'information et fragmentent la façon
dont nous recevons la formation joue à
plein régime il faut le rappeler les
réseaux sociaux certes il nous enferme
socialement on le sait mais c'est
important de le savoir il décide aussi
pour nous de ce que nous allons voir ça
veut dire que en fait vous avez tout un
discours contradictoire qui n'apparaît
plus aussi si vous êtes abonné à
certaines choses si vous suivez
certaines pages les algorithmes des
réseaux sociaux vont toujours vous
remontez les mêmes contenus et vous font
remonter les contenus qui vont vous
faire aller dans le sens de ce que vous
croyez donc ne pas vous montrer de
contradictions or l'un des principes de
la presse c'est aussi un moment ou un
autre que vous ayez des points de vue
qu'on traduit mais alors ce qui est
paradoxal c'est que dans ce baromètre on
a aussi ce chiffre qui est vraiment la
perception des personnes qui ont été
sondés par quant à juan pauline pour la
croix sur les réseaux sociaux 52% des
français estiment que leur apport est
mauvais que l'apport des réseaux sociaux
est mauvais ça peut sembler paradoxal
parce que je voyais ça et puis de
l'autre gars effectivement cet
enfermement qui nous guette tous plus ou
moins moi je vais faire leur avis du
village ce sondage annuel de la croix
way dont on se lamente chaque année deux
ans qu'est ce que l'image des
journalistes les mauvaises qu'est ce que
la défiance est forte il ya en fait des
éléments extrêmement positif de dents
qui sont à quoi la population aspire la
population elle aspire je dis ça de
mémoire parce que j'ai par hull sondages
aujourd'hui pas une information
indépendante fondée sur des faits
pluraliste est-ce que ça n'est pas
précisément l'idéal du journalisme donc
la critique finalement du journalisme
tel qu'on peut l'interpréter
dans l'étude de la croix elle est au nom
d'un idéal elle est une demande d'être à
ce niveau-là et donc ça c'est quand même
c'est positif oui les gens c'est un
disque dont on serait idéal déçu sanne
yde elle déçue ben oui
complète si l'aspiration elle était
vraiment différente oui mais ça c'est il
ya de quoi s'appuyer là dessus ça c'est
quand même je
jongle et de ce point de vue là elle
renvoie une défiance très forte qui vous
n'êtes pas suffisamment indépendant oui
et là
on peut vous pouvez les envoyer en
illustration mois ci un peu de choses à
faire dans les yeux
sur les mêmes arguments que 92 %
considèrent qu'il est essentiel que les
journées soit indépendant des pouvoirs
politiques et 91% des poires économique
mais à 32% pensent qu'ils sont un des
poudres et des pouvoirs économiques et
33% des pouvoirs train de pourrir des
pouvoirs politiques et 33% et poids
économique donc c'est vraiment un espoir
déçu oui mais quelque chose à faire
ouais comme ça
si je vais faire ma vie
reporters sans frontières aux portes 10
recommandations dix demandes et
revendications dans le cadre de la
campagne présidentielle au carré des
candidats il est évident que le cadre
juridique est inadaptée et que le cadre
juridique existant qui impose déjà et
notamment au conseil supérieur de
l'audiovisuel de faire respecter des
obligations en matière d'honnêteté de
l'information de pluralisme de
l'information et d'indépendance que ce
conseil sur perdre le duel je parle un
peu comme en anciens francs parce qu'il
a été rebaptisé janvier par comme que
l'art comme doit faire respecter à droit
constant
les obligations qui sont fixées par la
loi par la loi dite de 86 qui par
ailleurs est aujourd'hui caduc et ça
c'est un enjeu absolument essentielle et
il ya un test et vous il faisait
référence tout à l'heure c'est le cas
bolloré et demain matin demain bolloré
prend sa retraite officiellement c'est
les 200 ans de l'empiré bolloré
forêt semblablement
sa retraite sur un peu fictive mais il
ya un an je sais comment on évite
d'entrer dans une logique et qui renvoie
trump qui envoie la logique américaine
ces deux médias qui sont ultra polarisé
à ligne éditoriale univoque ou dumartin
soit du matin au soir au martel des
opinions du bla bla du commentaire
plutôt que d'apporter des informations
avec des visions effectivement
pluraliste et est alors avec une logique
foxnews à droite et de l'autre côté aux
etats-unis aussi une radicalisation
d'autres médias côté ds inscrit j'ai
tout à l'heure est concerné
et qui ont un effet désastreux sur la
population et on arrive à la fin avec
des catégories de population qui ne
veulent plus vivre dans le même pays est
ce que c'est ça quand on veut en france
si on ne veut pas ça il ya là un moment
historique il ne faut pas tout attendre
il faut mettre fin à cette dérive mais
comment
en faisant respecter l'indépendance
éditoriale
aujourd'hui par exemple l'ancienne armée
de la part de christophe elle peut avoir
des médias depuis dont je pense la
presse écrite il ya des journaux
d'opinion en france l'histoire de la
presse écrite c'est une histoire est
d'opinion avec des jambes ou qui étaient
marquées à gauche d'autres marqués à
droite ça allait mieux en le disant
parce qu'il me le disait la libération
est plutôt positionné à gauche c'est pas
un secret le figaro est plutôt
positionné à droite donc et ça les
empêche pas de faire un travail
journalistique
alors de deux réponses que soit le
figaro le monde libération donne la
parole à tout le monde on n'est pas dans
la logique foxnews où il ya eu une seule
parole la seconde chose c'est qu'en
france historiquement on a quelque chose
qui est très installé et là il ya la
question est est-ce qu'on veut le garder
c'est qu'il ya deux logiques différentes
en matière de pluralisme sur la presse
écrite ce qu'on appelle du pluralisme
externes c'est-à-dire une diversité de
médias qui peuvent avoir des lignes
différentes et s'agissant de la
télévision est une doctrine qui est le
pluralisme interne et le pluralisme
interne c'est un aspect fondamental
parce que c'est ce qui permet
précisément que sur des médias qui sont
des médias de plus grande masse on
puisse avoir des perceptions du monde
différente des visions du monde
différentes et des faits et il ya un
autre effet c'est que alors nous sommes
en dessous dans un studio en train de
discuter je faisais avant cette seule
armée il ya une chose qui à mon sens
c'est très dangereux c'est quand dans un
certain nombre d'émissions on ne
distingue plus qui sont les responsables
politiques qui sont les journalistes et
ne le saurai ton pas avant on serait
bien incapable de le deviner pendant
l'émission et ça je pense que c'est
désastreux
politique qui deviennent chroniqueur ça
dans l'histoire est toujours des gens
qui peuvent faire c'est d'un côté ou de
l'autre mais c'est surtout dans se tient
une confusion et on se dit finalement
les responsables politiques dont le rôle
c'est de légiférer décidée et s'est
fondue commentaires ce que pourra
finalement la raison d'être dit
politique à l inverse les journalistes
viennent de donner leur opinion sur
absolument tous et ça n'est pas lent sur
ses fonctions de l'indépendance je vous
propose d'entendre ce que ce qu'en dit
le fondateur du un ancien directeur du
monde eric fottorino
je pense que cette presse hyper
concentré ces groupes hyper concentré ce
sont des lieux où régulièrement pas tous
les jours on attache la liberté de la
presse l'indépendance et les rédactions
qu'il ya une sorte de perception par nos
citoyens les citoyens d'une connivence
entre la presse et les élites élites
politiques élites économiques l'idée de
ne plus être représenté de ne plus être
informés correctement voilà eric
fottorino au sénat puisque depuis
plusieurs semaines les sénateurs
auditionnent des des acteurs des grands
patrons de médias français les
milliardaires
actionnaires alors il ya cette question
de là
la connivence dont il parle au sein
d'une élite triangulaire on va dire
médias politiques patrons
et manison c'est une réalité c'est voilà
ça rejoint ce que vous disiez tout à
l'heure sur le décrochage en fait perçu
par l'opinion et car cela finalement
beaucoup de journalistes dans dans cette
même case moi oui c'est un petit monde
s'est un peu plus mende et c'est vrai
que quand on quand on parle avec
vraiment c'est ces gens qui sont qui
marque cette défiance énorme qui
aujourd'hui qui manifestent dans les
rues des gis légion du caudan t-rex
aujourd'hui qui sont vraiment au coeur
de cette défiance en fait il n'y a plus
aucune confiance dans tout ce qui est au
dessus c'est à dire cette caste qui
effectivement politiques journalistes
tous réunis qui ont tous menti à un
moment ou un autre dans leur tête et qui
donc ne fait que
ne fait que transmettre un message qui
est un message de mépris c'est simple en
fait quelqu'un que j'atteins nouvelles
récemment me parler d'eux des
journalistes en appel et narratif sert
quand vous parliez des mains de ce que
voilà on est les narratif on est ce
qu'ils inventent une histoire et puis
eux et quand vous parlez aussi
d'indépendance des médias pour eux un
média indépendant c'est pas du tout un
média qui a les moyens par exemple
économique de d'aller chercher
informations de la recouper de voyages
et de vérifier ce qui pour nous est la
base pour eux le média indépendant c'est
justement le journaliste enfin le
journaliste la personne qui a décidé de
rendre compte de l'événement seul sans
moyens généralement avec un petit
crowdfunding et quelques avec une petite
cagnotte est pour eux la presse les
médias indépendants c'est ça c'est le
gars qui va être sur le terrain mais qui
va être en fait en bedaine avec eux donc
là aussi là la notion d'indépendance aux
médias sans montage ça c'était une chose
qu'on avait beaucoup moins du moment
défilent et jodie c'est le côté vous
souvenez de sousse et vidéaste cdc le
journalisme sans montage en direct ses
ouailles de deux observations par
rapport à ce que vous dites c'est
toujours ce débat entre neutralité et
impartialité
mais c'est vrai que la presse écrite on
lui a jamais reproché d'avoir des points
de vue jamais le et quand vous lisez il
ya un acte volontaire si vous achetez le
figaro si vous achetez libéré si vous
achetez le monde vous savez ce que vous
faites est en revanche c'est une presse
impartial qui va donner la parole à tout
le monde devra tracer tout ce point de
vue après il ya des sujets qui vont plus
marqué est le déçu il ya des points de
vue qui ont un plus apporté enfin
globalement vous avez un compte rendu
ci non exhaustif en tout cas honnête de
l'actualité quand même quand même après
c'est pour ça qu'il faut faire la
différence avec la télévision georges 1
c'est pas la même chose mais intelligent
plus c'est ça qui est massif et c'est là
où les houles et où l'élite ce trouble
et la deuxième chose moi je suis assez
frappé et plus je réfléchi à ça plus
j'entend et tout ce qui se passe autour
du duc de des débats actuels de cette
défiance montre si une chose il ya une
défaite collective de notre profession
mais nous avons
laissé penser à tout le monde que le
journaliste que la presse s'était pas un
vrai métier c'était pas un vrai secteur
que y'avait pas des compétences
professionnelles ce que vous dites c'est
parce qu'on a dit que c'était gratuit
quoi alors ça c'est fondamental alors là
alors une dimension tout n'est pas
payant mais au moins il faut expliquer
aux gens que c'est quand même payer à un
moment internet a bouleversé les choses
on laisse croire à des gens que
l'information elles tombent du ciel
qu'en fait elle n'est pas rémunéré qu'il
n'y a pas des gens qui la fabrique
derrière ça c'est une chose qui a chanté
changé la deuxième chose c'est nous
devons collectivement pour ré asseoir
cette confiance moi j'en suis sûr nous
devons réaffirmer que produire de
l'information c'est pas un gros mot
c'est un vrai métier il ya des règles il
y a de la déontologie
il ya des compétences professionnelles
le nombre de journalistes soit disant
indépendants et encore une fois ces mots
sont à manier avec beaucoup de
précaution mais qui se sont retrouvés
eux aussi à un moment confrontés à des
problèmes que nous avons tous rencontrés
sur le terrain qu'est ce que je dis
qu'est ce que je raconte c'est quoi le
point de vue c'est quoi la hiérarchie de
l'information en fait on aucun d'entre
nous ne se verrait s'improviser
ingénieurs chimistes du jour au
lendemain mais le journaliste alors ça
tout le monde tout le monde mais à
pattes c'est pas vrai c'est pas vrai et
je le dis parce que c'est pas simplement
la défense d'une corporation il ya des
gens qui sont formés professionnellement
quelque chose et il ya des gens qui
parlent un match au stade qui par
exemple sur des médias il ya des chaînes
youtube qui sont pas du tout des médias
traditionnels qui sont d'immenses
qualités mais vraiment prenez hugo
décrit prenaient tous ces gens là qui
ont fondé un travail remarquable mais
ils appliquent des règles
professionnelles ils le font ils disent
pas n'importe quoi et c'est bien qu'ils
appliquent des professionnels mais
christophe on pourrait considérer aussi
si on essaie d'être un peu positif que
la période c'est une vraie opportunité
pour les journalistes parce que il ya
une partie de l'opinion qui ne se
satisfait pas d'être confrontés à ce ce
bombardement d'informations
contradictoires d'informations non
vérifiées 2
deux rumeurs partagé par son cercle sur
les réseaux sociaux et qui donc vous
pourrait se dire allons vers les
professionnels qui vont se vérifier les
informations et les transmettre et donc
s'abonner à ces médias qui font leur
travail est ce que vous vous dites il ya
une opportunité ou est ce que vous dites
le combat on l'a perdu une opportunité
mais le combat il pourra pas être
individuel en fait c'est un combat
politique où il faut obtenir un
changement du cadre législatif ou
matthieu croissandeau disais tout à
l'heure
parler du filtre et c'est vrai que d'une
certaine manière le journalisme ça
représente un filtre alors au sens
positif par l'application des règles
déontologiques par les méthodes
professionnelles mais ce filtre ils
gênent deux types de parties prenantes
aujourd'hui ils viennent tous les
pouvoirs tous ceux qui ont envie de
faire un récit sur eux-mêmes qui
préfèrent le faire directement
franchement c'est mieux qu'on soit
responsable politique conçu une
entreprise conçoit un club de football
ou même des belligérants dans une guerre
voire un groupe djihadiste donc le
filtre il est gênant
et le public parfois trouve ce filtre
aussi gênant parce que finalement on
n'est pas conforté dans ses propres
intérêts donc
simplement choisi c'est à ma place en
fait tant qu'elle ne suffira pas que les
journalistes fassent merveilleusement
leur travail avec la plus grande
abnégation de manière parfaite pour
justifier la confiance qu'on pourrait
leur faire dans ce cas il faut changer
l'organisation du marché parce
qu'aujourd'hui on a d'un côté le fait de
représenter cette forme de filtres donne
un désavantage concurrentiel
on est avantagé dans l'écosystème de
l'information aujourd'hui si on balance
des rumeurs
sur ma propre à donner sa course i fois
plus vite sur les résolutions une
édition du meilleur direct c'est mon
scénario à vérifier donc il faut
s'attacher à reconstruire ce marché de
l'information cet écosystème et le
marché de l'information disons le c'est
la délibération publique donc c'est
fondamentalement démocratique et de ce
point de vue là en distinguant les
aspects c'est à dire les aspects
structurels et puis les phénomènes à
l'intérieur du site alors il ya je
reviens nos sonore enfin
passage interview d'eric fottorino teurs
il y avait une autre critique était à la
concentration des médias emmanuelle
anizon l'ops appartient au groupe le
monde
qui a pour actionnaires principaux
xavier niel mathieu pigasse au
milliardaire tchèque daniel christine
ski alors je voudrais juste que vous
disais comment l'indépendance de la
rédaction de l'obs et protégés est ce
qu'il ya un système particulier il ya
dit évidemment un système particulier
dans la mesure où un actionnaire ne peut
pas intervenir dans une rédaction enfin
tout simplement est un média il ya des
yé des filtres qui empêche est
actionnaire en intervenir il ya
directeur ou une directrice de la
rédaction qui est là pour s'occuper
d'éditorial il ya éventuellement des
sociétés de rédacteurs de journalistes
qui surveille cette indépendance
et puis après il y a il y a chaque
journaliste enfin j'veux dire il ya
le le
le sens de notre métier l'indépendance
le l'éthique enfin gérant l'apprend à
l'école et surtout on l'a on la vrille
et au corps enfin normalement en tout
cas c'est comme ça que je conçois ce
métier donc mais cette question par
exemple de xavier niel actionnaire du
monde je laisse systématiquement face de
moi quand je suis sur le terrain avec
avec ces populations anti vague gilet
jaune c'était systématiquement me dit
mais vous c'est xavier niel donc après
il faut passer du temps et puis il faut
montrer que en fait on fait son boulot
moi je veux dire jeu par rapport à ses
pieds pardon et noir à cette question
alors pareil c'est peut-être caricatural
et jamais le meilleur moyen d'assurer
l'indépendance des médias c'est de payer
pour ses vertus évidemment évidemment je
dis pas et je pense que là plein
d'égards il faut réfléchir sur
énormément d'indépendance
personnellement j'ai travaillé dans un
groupe public un groupe privé des
frictions on va dire enfin honnêtement
on peut aussi faire très très très
honnêtement son métier même s'il ya des
phénomènes de concentration est là le
jour j on a totalement qui finissent par
être inquiétant mais le meilleur moyen
d'un sud de donner aux journalistes et
donc à la presse qu'on a envie de lire
d'écouter de voir le look de leur donner
les moyens de cette indépendance est
bien c'est de la financer il ya beaucoup
de gens en france notamment par rapport
à d'autres pays c'est aussi un pays où
justement on n'aime pas ça venez
regarder muller times alors certes il y
avait un contexte particulier et c'est
ça ma faim ils ont battu des record
d'abonnements il ya un an vous donnez
vous offrez à un journal aussi des
moyens des moyens considérables et
derrière bah ça veut dire des enquêtes
ça veut dire de la dénonciation ça veut
dire des enquêtes coup de poing ça veut
dire des reportages de qualité alors je
voudrais vous proposer une dernière
séquence de ce moment elle m'a tellement
sera puis je voulais qu'on l'a qu'on la
revoit et ça va rejoindre les enquêtes
que vous que vous avez signé pour pour
l'obs c'est notre confrère pour la pole
la route ou qe sur lci et qui suit le
convoi
autoproclamé de la liberté où des
libertés regarder voyez les chiffres y
manque tout est faux il n'ya pas le
nombre de morts que vous croyez c'est
une aberration mentale de millions de
morts dans le monde des centaines de
milliers de demandes dans le france il
ya trois millions de morts par pour les
automobiles il ya 3 millions demeure
pour pour la cigarette ils sont morts
d'une grippe je peux pas parler à des
gens qui ne comprennent rien à ce jour
n'est pas passé parce que vous me
comprenez elle vient de dire quelque
chose d'essentiel je peux pas parler des
gens qui ne comprennent rien et on en
est là dans le débat public c'est partir
du moment où l'opinion a remplacé les
faits oui vous avez plus de terrain de
jeu commun pour débattre et pour nous
notre métier c'est très très compliqué
parce qu'on ne provoquera pas cette dame
ni avec les meilleurs articles alors il
analysé ouais mais enfin
c'est serré ça pouvait ramener dans le
travail de fourmi notamment quand alors
je sais pas naïve que dire qu'il faut du
temps et du terrain mais vraiment c'est
à dire que c'est des heures quoi c'est
des heures de le convaincre
de nouveaux
rédaction vous envoyez des journées ils
sont juste chargé
de faire du renom mais de faire du
boulot en passant du temps et après
quand le quand le conte article leur
semble honnête
et quand le retour c'est comme là j'ai
eu beau me dit bon on voit bien vous
n'êtes pas d'accord avec nous mais vous
nous avez pas caricaturer n'ai pas trahi
vous n'êtes pas mon bon c'est un début
c'est à petit je pense qu'on en est là
aujourd'hui je pense qu'il ya un
problème
rétablir la confiance par le haut on ne
va pas c'est trop tard c'est raté on est
bon on est beaucoup trop loin là pendant
qu'on voit la liberté j'ai assisté à une
scène surréaliste aussi où un
journaliste s'est fait vraiment étrillé
tout le monde hurlait bfm collabos
collabos collabos le team le gars
c'était juste c'était un gars de la
provence du coin et qui leur disaient
mais moi ça fait deux ans que je bosse
sur ses skis c'est la prime au leader
moi j'ai eu ça quand on était à tf1
c'est au tour baudet tf1 pour y deux ans
sur cette question aurait dit on elle
raconté c'est très long ça va être très
long je voudrais terminer comme sur la
responsabilité des politiques peut-être
avec boukris au dollar parce que on
parlait de valérie pécresse mais c'est
pas celle qui est la plus violente mais
c'est vrai quand annie d'observateurs
sont des bigorneaux après il ya aussi
des candidats qui font siffler les
journalistes dans leurs meetings voilà
les mots sont violents et parfois ils
deviennent des actes violents il ya une
responsabilité politique dans la
pression qui est mise sur les
journalistes et dans cette défiance qui
ce qui se creusent les responsables
politiques qui par les mots par les noms
d'oiseaux infligé
admoneste les journalistes enfin
effectivement parfois dans des meetings
peuvent être extrêmement violent ceux
qui prônent la haine des journalistes
etc portent une responsabilité et
porteront une responsabilité encore plus
lourde le jour où quelqu'un passera à
l'acte et soyons clairs dans si on
regarde l'ensemble des pays en france on
a encore échappé à il ya eu la tragédie
de charlie hebdo mais ça n'est pas une
responsabilité politique
on n'a pas eu comme malheureusement ça a
été le cas dans d'autres pays aux états
unis trump a insulté les journalistes il
ya un type qui dans le maryland a
déboulé dans une heure et d'action avec
une arme et a tué cinq journalistes au
capitole gazette
en slovaquie et de l'union européenne le
premier ministre de l'époque robert
phipps eau pendant 10 on a qualifié les
journalistes de yens il a même employé
ce terme dans une conférence de presse à
bruxelles et un journaliste de données
qui ne rencontre est même pas deux
personnes dangereuses a fini par être
assassiné par manifestement des mafieux
ce qui
affaiblissent la fonction journalistique
par leurs mots on crée les conditions du
passage à l'acte et ça c'est extrêmement
dangereux je pense que tous les
responsables politiques qui aujourd'hui
sont virulents ferait bien de s'en
aviser merci beaucoup merci à tous les
quatre on a essayé de ne pas être
troupes autour centre est par définition
à des basses comme celui là entre
journalisme et voilà je pense que c'est
aussi un enjeu démocratique vous l'avez
compris c'est pour ça qu'on a décidé
d'en parler dans cette émission jean
bernage rappel le titre de votre livre
coécrit avec thomas huchon anti fait que
nous le livre indispensable pour démêler
le vrai du faux c'est aux éditions first
je vous dis à 2